bonjour virginie martin merci de
répondre à nos questions sur arte france
après house of cards et baron noir c'est
marseille sans dessus dessous
quand on voit des jeux d'alliance comme
ça on se dit pas que finalement après un
taux d'abstention record dimanche
dernier qu'on comprend les français
s'ils semblent se désintéresser de la
politique au nom de désintérêt de la
politique des deux bien plus longtemps
que cela et marcel n'y est pas pour
grand chose finalement
non il faut peut-être aussi mieux
regarder cette fameuse loi paris lyon
marseille qui vient troubler énormément
le jeu démocratique
alors ça ne se voit pas à lyon ni à
paris parce que les candidats ont eu des
majorité suffisante et donc on ne voit
pas toutes ces tractations qui sont en
train de se passer à marseille mais en
fait paris lyon et marseille sont
soumises ces trois villes sont soumises
à la même loi électorale dont qui
concerne ces trois villes
et ça donne ce genre de truc quand il
n'y a pas assez de sièges quand les
majorités ne sont pas assez solides et
bien il y à ce genre de tractations
donc oui ça donne peut-être une mauvaise
image mais il pourrait y avoir la même
chose à paris à léon tout cas donc
marseille deuxième ville de france
formèrent ce n'est pas un cas de figure
inédit d'après ce que vous dites
ce n'est pas un cas de figure et des
îles et les les votes comme ça se font
en soit il faut à un moment donné lire
le maire don pour élire le maire il faut
évidemment des majorités ou absolue dans
un premier temps puis relative faute de
mieux et donc c'est comme cela que
cestas et le code électoral qui le veut
d'accord donc ça c'est important quand
même de le remettre dans le contexte
maintenant de toute façon en fin d'après
midi ou même dans la journée assez
rapidement marseille aura un maire
vraisemblablement après qu'est-ce qui se
passera ça reste à voir
parce que la légitimité du maire qui va
sortir aujourd'hui des urnes et donc de
l'hémicycle à marseille
ce sera quand même questionné c'est une
légitimité compliqué à cause de ce mode
de scrutin qui donc qui est la loi plm
qui donne finalement des voix par
exemple la le printemps marseillais donc
l'union de la gauche a eu treize mille
voix de plus que la droite ait
finalement la droite pourrait à la fin
emporté la donne on me souffle et les
mots de la bouche vous parler de deux
légitimités justement je voulais vous
poser cette question le maire qui sera
élu quelle sera sa véritable légitimité
est ce qu'elle sera entendue et s'il
serait très compliqué honnêtement ça ça
va être très compliqué puis peut y avoir
aussi des alliances un peu contre nature
alors les alliances un peu plus
naturelle serait évidemment ruby rôle à
samia ghali l'alliance un peu moins
naturel politiquement serait samia ghali
guy teissier dont vous voyez que entre
les alliances un peu forcée des
politiquement plus cohérente et des
alliances politiquement incohérente mais
peut-être moins force et la légitimité
va se poser aussi en toile de fond mais
aussi l'entente la confiance
comment vous dire les grandes majorités
comment allait prendre des belles
décision grandement soutenue par tous et
toutes
une fois que finalement l'alliance si je
puis dire de la carpe et du lapin
pourrait pourrait avoir lieu
tout ça va être très compliqué et ça
pourrait aussi donner pourquoi pas
encore un dernier coup d'éclat avec
conseil municipal qui pourrait aussi
partiellement démissionner et donc on
sera obligé de recommencer ces élections
et est-ce qu'on pourrait se retrouver
avec une sorte de cohabitation entre un
maire et son premier adjoint
ça c'est difficile c'est difficile on le
voit alors bon maintenant on peut on
pourrait dire si par exemple dit et s'il
était maire de marseille et que samia
ghali devenez sa première adjointe
depuis ce qu'il a eu à proposer on
pourrait dire que c'est une forme de
cohabitation politique mais non les
accords se font quand même avant et on
n'est pas là en cohabitation au sens
plein du terme mais maintenant il va
quand même falloir en trouver des grande
majorité parce que la cohabitation vous
voyez c'est pas pareil le président de
la république ne vient pas comme ça
devant l'assemblée nationale faire voter
ses lois etc
c'est pas la même chose au premier
ministre et à présent dans le public
tandis que là un maire et un premier
adjoint ont besoin quand même de penser
les mêmes les mêmes choses et de penser
ensemble donc non la cohabitation au
sens où on l'entend n'est pas possible
est-ce qu'elle ne s'était à la fois
saine fracturé en 3 d'un côté les
quartiers nord et l'autre côté à
l'éducation
oui oui c'est bien sûr bien sûr je
dirais peut-être fracturé en 3 plutôt
qu'en deux je trouve que le 2 est un peu
caricatural il ya les quartiers nord
c'est certain il ya les quartiers sud
c'est vrai mais il faut aussi rajouter
finalement une sorte de zone mixte qui
est le centre et le coeur de marseille
le coeur de la vie donc il composé du 2è
3è arrondissement premier qui est autour
du vieux-port grosso modo 1 pour faire
vite et là je trouve qu'on oublie
souvent que c'est là une terre de belle
mixité tout de même et donc c'est la
ville est un peu plus complexe que cela
il ya aussi dans les quartiers sud
ddd poche comme ça deux quartiers très
modeste village modeste de petites cités
il ya aussi dans les quartiers nord de
très belles choses et qui vont très très
bien donc il ne faut pas non plus trop
caricaturé comme je l'entends souvent
sur cette ville et puis aussi le mot par
exemple la bouillabaisse électorale
marseillaise vient non c'est pas une
bouillabaisse et ce que je vous ai
expliqué en préambule c'est juste la loi
paris lui rend marseille et ça n'a rien
à voir avec la bouillabaisse locale
dernière question le rn qui claque la
porte du conseil municipal un moment
aussi décisif qu'est-ce que ça traduit
d'ailleurs stéphane ravier qui sera de
retour ensemble de l'émission
on sait pas pourquoi si vous savez
pourquoi vous pourrez peut-être avant à
voir notre interview j'ai essayé de
savoir pourquoi et qu'est-ce qu'ils
avaient faim dont je n'en sais pas plus
que vous puisqu'on a pris l'antenne à
pile à ce moment là mais oui oui il est
en train de revenir
qu'est ce que ça veut dire est-ce que
derrière ils vont finalement travailler
en fait à avoir des majorités plus
complexe parce que là finalement on
était à une majorité nécessaire à 46,47
voir selon qui s'abstient ou pas et avec
le rassemblement national revenus et
bien c'est neuf sièges qu'ils reviennent
potentiel est donc une majorité absolue
relative qui sont en nombre en tout cas
vous voyez c'est ça qui peut peut-être
changer le nombre fait le calcul
arithmétique
je ne suis pas sûr en revanche qu'il
s'exprime véritablement pour tel ou tel
protagoniste
voilà ça sera plutôt arithmétique dans
les calculs et les suffrages mais je ne
suis pas sûr qu'ils aillent de se porter
sur sabia galy sur michel rubio là aussi
on dit teyssier ça m'étonnerait merci
virginie martin d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
politologue et enseignant de chercheuse
à l'école ketchup business school de
marseille on reste donc focalisés sur
marseille à la mi journée pour savoir de
quelle couleur sera la fumée qui sortira
de l'hôtel de ville de la cité phocéenne